a city populated with characters from
sagas the historic district of Hameln is
full of the heroes of fairy tales and
legends and plenty of rats too they
recall the most famous character from a
German saga the Pied Piper he is
supposed to have lived more than 700
years ago but even today most people
have heard of him siberian shipston is
just a lovely story that's passed down
from generation to generation add
cinematography would ensure a majority
cap with a feather that's a pied piper
for meme colorfully closed lucky
sometimes walks around here in hameln I
know him from fairy tale books my
parents used to read to me what made the
Pied Piper famous was the collection of
German sagas compiled by the brothers
jakub and vill him Grimm 200 years ago
they published a volume with many folk
tales like the one about the musician
who freed hameln of rats when the people
of Hameln refused to pay him he lured
away all the children with his music the
Grimm's didn't invent the story but they
made the Pied Piper world-famous this
legend has been translated into more
than 30 languages the Pied Piper story
profited from the popularity of the
Grimm brothers other work it's very
popular all over the english-speaking
world and Europe Asia to as many fans of
the Pied Piper and of legends and fairy
tales in general noggin vikas double
and hameln profits to each year some 3.8
million people visit the city to walk in
the footsteps of the Pied Piper or to
experience him live for the past 22
years Michael Boyer has been Hamlin's
official Pied Piper the US citizen has
known the story since childhood he have
shown in the traditional class I read
about the Pied Piper when I was in third
grade I didn't believe the story with
its Piper who could lead rats and
children out of town with his magic and
a mare who refuses to pay him I can't do
anything about it a magical story with
magical music sword and then when I
learned that the city of hominin really
exists I thought well that's great you
learn something new every day he lay on
the desk the Grimm brothers collected
many of their fascinating stories in
castle where they lived for a long time
at the interactive museum Grimm vet
visitors can encounter the best known
characters from the collection the Frog
Prince and Snow White's Seven Dwarves
but Yakov anvil hmmm were more than
fairytale collectors they studied law
went into politics and launched the
first German dictionary the mammoth
project wasn't completed until after
their deaths aha Jesus I took which we
collected these old cultural artifacts
the fairy tale sagas and put them in a
consistent form thereby making these
stories famous all over the world
Grimm's fairy tales have inspired many
artists and have often been turned into
films or cartoons they appear in early
silhouette animation and in cartoons
like Puss in Boots
Hollywood still likes to adapt Grimm's
fairy tales as with its recent
oscar-nominated live-action retelling of
Cinderella the Pied Piper story has also
been filmed many times the Disney
cartoon version from 1933 is well known
but what distinguishes a legend from a
fairy tale zagreb sagas or legends
always have at least a grain of
historical truth for example the pied
piper of Hameln something like that
really did happen here so orders all in
the cotton finger of I hereby Piper was
here in the bungalows and stars which
means the drumless street so the street
without music an inscribed beam on a
building there tells the story of the
Pied Piper 20 meters of eyewitness
accounts what more could you want yeah
weather legend or fairy tale the stories
collected by the Brothers Grimm are
still loved by children particular even
after 200 years they stink at dusty I
think the Brothers Grimm is still
present everywhere in children's rooms
everyone here is about the brothers
grimm fairy tales at some point it's
really a trademark people know the
Brothers Grimm so the 200th anniversary
of the Grimm's collections of Legends is
being enthusiastically celebrated in
various cities all along Germany's
fairytale route and we hope everyone
lives happily ever after